do rich and poor men get cheated on the  same or no do rich so if you had if you  had like 50 clients like they were  wealthy and 50 you know maybe maybe the  poor ones couldn't really afford you so  you don't know  but 50 clients that are poor like would  you say like they get equally cheated on  um  a great question you know I've  represented so many men who were poor  and they got cheated on and then so many  men who were rich and they got cheated  on  um but also you can have poor men who  are married to this woman and the woman  knows that she's poor and they're not  living right and she'll be faithful to  that man and similarly you can have a  man who's making you know  30 million dollars and the wife is  faithful so I'm sure along some lines  income has something to do with it but  at the end of the day it's going to  depend much more on the personality of  the woman